so
yeah the point is you know there are
many ways to sample one bit in like
steps and
though those are I will mainly focus on
this way which is kind of a canonical
way to uh sample a bit continuously and
by continuously I mean that you know the
expected entropy gain that you have in
every infinitesimal time change DT is
also in Fairly decimal
um so you kind of you know you generate
the the bits continuously rather than
you know in discrete steps
okay so let's let's focus on this and
first let's try to prove that
uh such a thing actually exists
starting RDL so you know what we want is
the following then
we have
so this is this is our time it goes from
zero to one
and uh
this axis is like you know the value of
x t this is T and
we want a process that is always
either equal to
plus d or minus t so it always stays on
one of these two lines
but since it's a Martingale it has to
jump between the two so you know it's
probably look gonna look like this like
jumps between them and then maybe it
stays on this one for a bit and then you
know it jumps up here and then it stays
on this one for a bit and then it's it
jumps down
Etc
so this is
um
this is the graph of x t
and you know in the end it ends up at
either like plus or minus
and you know the reason it has to jump
is once it got here
it is a Martin game right so so the
probability to get to
you know plus and minus one given that
you are like here at some value Alpha
must be proportional to you know the
ratio between like these two intervals
right I mean it has to be that the
expectation of X1
given x t
is x t
so basically you know whether I'm on
this line and on this line and if I know
T it uniquely defines
you know it's
uh what the probabilities are to reach
plus or minus one in the end and it's
also uniquely defines the like uniquely
determined sorry the probability is to
reach like plus or minus so so suppose
here and this is Xs
so for any T bigger than S
this is some T bigger than us
the probability to be either here or
here is uniquely determined by you know
where what XS is whether or not it's
plus s or minus
and in general this process is also
uniquely defined
and uh I guess one way uh to think about
this process is you can take actually in
Brownian motion
so this is the Brownian motion uh BT
and then you can define a continuous
family of stopping times
so
of t
is
just the
minimal
value of s such that
D of s
in absolute value is equal to T
so you know for for every ta look at the
first time that
the Brownian motion reaches the value t
the in in absolute value so I get some
you know sequence
of stopping times mating beats here here
and then these ones and then I don't
know these ones or whatever in them here
and then I can just Define uh
x t is
the Brownian motion at Talk t
and this will give me a process that you
know
satisfies
these two pro properties
or we can just actually
Define it directly by
basically
calculating what the probability is to
jump between this line and this line at
any given instant so
like suppose x t is equal to plus t
for something
then
now consider
the distribution
of x t plus DT
conditioned on x d so here I'm going to
be I'm not going to be completely
rigorous
and
and from now on what I wanna so so you
know DT is infinitesimal and we and
everything is kind of on a continuous
time scale but from now on
will do everything only spam I
rigorously
and
we'll just imagine
or not imagine will just stay you know
will fix
a small number
and
say that DT is not infinitesimal it's
just one over a million
okay and we'll only evaluate our
processes on
so we'll only consider the case word t
is some multiple of DT so T will always
be
you know in Z times DT I think this is a
really good way to kind of
uh factor out
of the
I mean all the extra technical work you
have to do in order to make things you
know really work in continuous time so
we'll do all sorts of heuristic
calculations but it's everything is
going to be correct in the limit I just
don't want to waste time going to the
Limit
so okay
um
so this was kind of in parenthesis and
now consider the distribution of X at
time t plus DT given x t so you know x t
plus DT
is going to be equal to
either Plus
t plus DT
and this is going to happen with
probability
some P that will calculate soon or minus
t plus DT
and this is going to happen with
probability one minus B
and now let's try to understand what the
value of P should be okay so we know
that XTS would be a Martingale meaning
that you know the expectation of x t
plus DT is equal to
condition the next day
has to be equal to x t in which we
assumed is equal to actually maybe let's
even do it in general
so
so this is this half this is to be equal
to XT which is either plus or minus d
right
and
on the other hand this is equal to you
know p
times uh
t plus DT
Plus
1 minus B
times
minus t plus DT
okay let's actually assume this is equal
to plus t as we wrote above the second
should it be minus t minus DT because
the negative minus t my sorry sorry but
minuses
sorry
sure
and now you know we
let's let's just solve these equations
and if we store these equations we get
basically that P is equal
to uh
actually maybe sorry let me let let me
flip the roles because let me call this
one minus pin this B because I want P to
be that probability to actually make a
jump
sorry I just
flip the rows of these two so you know
this event is just
it just means that you know X
T jumps
the process takes the jumps between
time t
and time
t plus DT
right and like this event corresponds to
the fact that it just kind of stays on
the same uh
you know
linear curve
so you know if we move uh things around
What will what we'll get is that P is
something like
one
over
2T
well not exactly it's like
one over two t plus something that's you
know up to a multiplicative Factor
something that goes to one as DT goes to
zero but we will just ignore this
because it's going to go to zero and all
of the calculations so you know
conveniently I'll just assume
that it's just the probability to jump
is just exactly one over two t
okay so I have a probability of one over
two t to dump distance
minus 2T and you know the rest which is
like
sorry uh I'm sorry it's DT over t two t
so I have a probability of DT over 2T
to jump a distance that looks like minus
2T which is jumping from something like
plus d to minus t
and then the rest which is one minus
this o of DT
to you know jump something that only
looks like
DT
and you know
these two things are zero up to
um
o of DT squared
okay
so
you you can just I mean
in a stand this formula just completely
determines what this process is
so this process is just
you know it's going gone one of these
two lines
and then in each you know infinitesimal
interval of length detail you have this
probability of DT over 2T to jump to the
other side
and note that you know the the function
one over two two t
diverges near zero so one over two t
this integral diverges
near a zero
and that means that when we get close to
zero here
it's going to jump an infinite amount of
times
but it's actually integrable when we go
to you know when we are bounded away
from zero meaning that between any point
here
and one there is only going to be
finitely many jobs
let me just wait five seconds to save
their questions about this process
okay so you can just you can like
literally think of DTS being a small
number and then you know it's a process
that either moves like a very small
distance like DT or jumps to the other
side but this happens with a much
smaller probability
okay good
now
so we have this process and
now let me go back to uh a little bit
for what we had before so
suppose that XD
so
suppose that x t is any Martingale
status find that X zero is zero
and X
1 is 1.
is starting
one in absolute value
so
it's just a way to sample it a random
bit
so I can Define
just the vector value process XD
such that uh x i of t
has the distribution of like this
process
so let's just
say all the coordinates are IID with
uh
log
of
you know the process txt
so we just take you know an independent
copies of this Martingale so now we get
a Marvel you know not in the interval
minus one one but in the continuous
hyper Cube minus one one to the n
okay so this is
a Marvin Gaye to the n
and
you know for
f
uh
multi-linear
extension
of a Boolean function but actually of
any function
foreign
we can Define
the Martingale Mt
to be equal to f
of
XD
so just recall before we had a very
specific and simple Martingale that you
know started from the center here and
every iteration we I mean we had a
discrete
time access and every iteration we
picked the coordinate and then we moved
to plus minus one in this coordinates
until we ended in a corner now we just
say okay this is more General I can take
any more
in plus one one I take independent
copies of it and I plug you know this
thing into the
multi-linear extension
and
they claim that you know empty
constructed this way is always a market
regardless of you know what the process
XD was
and the reason is that
if I take F I can just write f
F of this vector
as the sum
just the Fourier decomposition
of
these terms
and it's enough to show that
that each such product is an organelle
so enough to show that for every a
those guys are Nightingales and they're
and you know for all a
this product
sorry this is Ina this product
is a product
of
independent
martingales
and it's a one-line exercise to show
that a product of independent
martingales is a Martingale and also the
sum of martials is a modern deal
so this so empty is an article okay
now recall that in the proof of the Quan
Quran inequality what we basically said
is okay if I have a Martingale a very
natural thing to to look at is the sum
of square differences
of this Martingale and this is always
going to be equal to the variance
right this is basically just uh
I guess sometimes it's called Uh
Edo's isometry or
I guess it also is the name in discrete
time which I don't remember
so when when time is continuous it's not
very clear so we want some notion we
recall that
foreign
was discrete
we had this notion of some of
differences that you know looked like
this
but now time is continuous so the
question is is there
you know an analog this quantity
and the answer is yes when the time is
continuous you can just
take some limit so this is called
quadratic variation
kind of like canonical
property of any any Martingale in
particular continuous martingales or
jump Morgan
so for any really stochastic process
empty
we're going to Define its quadratic
variation M with those square brackets d
as the limits
as Epsilon goes to zero of this exact
same thing only I you know I stump over
a grid of
size Epsilon so let's just take this
down over all t
or I already have t sorry all s
in
the interval 0 T intersection with
Epsilon times the integers
and then take here M as minus
um
S Plus Epsilon
squared
so this is just you know the sum of
squares of jumps
and
it's not clear a priori that you know
this thing this limit actually exists
but it turns out that it always exists
when we have the marginal and they think
we were going to more or less see why
this is the case later
and now
ethos isometry
is telling us and the proof is basically
exactly the proof we saw before with a
little bit of extra technical details
that the variance
of
M it's time t
uh
maybe conditions
okay sorry I have I think I have no
choice but uh
no okay no okay I'm gonna avoid
Define infiltrations still the variance
of am at time t
is just equal or maybe let's let me save
minus M A Time s where any T and S
is equal to the expectation the
difference
between the quadratic variation and time
and S
and the quadratic variation eternity
so it's just the expectation of you know
the stomach Square differences
it's kind of like the generalization
what we saw before
okay
great
so you know all all this is like very
general I mean it's it's true for any
Martingale and now let's try to see what
it means
for the Martingale we just defined here
okay
so
if we take you know t
to be One S to be zero in this formula
then the left hand side is just the
variance of f
which as you remember we usually want to
balance I mean I didn't say what we're
trying to prove but we are usually
proving some kind of concentration and
quality so we want an upper balance of
the variance of f usually
and
you know by ito's isometry this is just
equal to
the expectation of the quadratic
variation
of the Martingale time one and this is
you know
true for any any way to sample those
random bits so if we just sample them as
in the proof of the point inequality we
exactly get
what we start above which is just those
sums of squares of differences but now
let's look at this jump process and see
and try to understand what the quadratic
variation means in this case
so in this case time is continuous
so let's write this thing as an integral
from zero to one
of
the expectation
M at time t plus DT and by being
slightly informal here but again think
of DT is being you know just a small
number
foreign
or a telescopic integral if you want
and now let's try to understand what is
the difference in quadratic variation
between the marginal time t plus DT and
the Martingale time t
so
uh
yeah
so maybe yeah let me do one more step
here
this is basically equal to the integral
between 0 and 1.
of the expectation
of
m
t plus DT minus m
t
squared
uh
sorry and I don't need to write a DT
here
um
because this is this is already in
infinite testimony
and also here I don't need to write DT
this this thing is really the order of
DT right
so this is equal to the integral between
0 and 1 of so M was f of x t so it's
just
the expectation of
f F at X
t plus DT
minus F at
X
t
squared
right
sorry
let me just move this a tiny bit
okay
and
and let's try to understand what this
thing is
okay
so
first of all if there is no jump
if
you know none of the coordinates of X
jumped at all
then
x t plus DT it's distance from x t
no coordinates jumped
then
x t plus DT
minus x t
is for maybe like the norm of this is O
of DT
and since f is uh lip sheets or
continuous or I mean it's lip sheets
then this means that F at X
ah sorry I'm
plus DT
F at x t plus DT
minus F at
x t
is
also you know
o of DT
not sure what's happening
all right
something is still weird with my iPhone
sorry about it
which means that if I Square it I get DT
squared
so
you know this thing squared is oh is
little o d t
so when we integrate it we just get zero
so we kind of only care about the jumps
now if DT is small only one coordinate
is going to you know jump at most
unless like so
the probability
that
more than one
coordinate
jumps
between
t and t plus DT
is also if if the coordinates are
independent and each coordinate as
probability order DT to jump
this is also little DT it's again like
DT Square
so we can really ignore the contribution
coming from
the case where no coordinates jumped and
the case that more than one coordinate
is jumped
so we only care about the contribution
of
coming from the case that's exactly one
coordinates made a jump
so this is going to be equal to
the integral between 0 and 1 and now I
sum over all coordinates
and I take the probability
that
x i of t
jumped
between
t and t plus DT
and when this coordinate jumped by
by how much okay given that this
coordinate jumped what is the value of
this difference well
I claim that it's basically the
derivative in the ith coordinate
of f
at XD
times
the distance of the jump which is
equal to 2T
squared
any questions about
so you know I kind of handwaved this but
hopefully it's
intuitive enough any questions about
like
this equality
okay
and now we know what the probability is
for according to jump It's it looks like
we calculated or
at least more or less calculated that's
it's equal to
DT over 2T
so I'm just going to
replace this by DT over 2T
and what I get is the integral between 0
and 1. summer coordinates
DT over 2T
Del i f
x t
sorry for that the expectation
and there is also an expectation here
DT over 2T Del i f x t times tier t
squared
uh
which is just equal to
the expectation and the integral between
0 and 1 of
the gradient of F at x t
Norm squared
2 T Square over 2T just gives me
2T so
times T DT
okay so we got a formula for the
variance of f
in terms of what in terms of the norm of
the gradient of F at various points
inside the continuous High hyperview
okay
and this is like very
this is very close to the formula we
stopped before when we prove that one
Korean inequality
that basically said that
um
yeah
so this formula so that
I guess they never so so the variance of
f was equal to the sum of those squares
which in turn were equal to something
that has to do with the partial
derivatives of f evaluating along this
process XD
so now we just have another process but
the principle is exactly the same and
really for any Martingale we Define
those for any sampling procedure we
defined we're going to automatically get
a corresponding representation for the
variance so this is just the
representation for the variance coming
from this particular Martingale that
that is the junk process
okay
good
so now let's try to use this thing in
order to show
or maybe
maybe let's summarize just a little bit
we have that the variance of that
is equal to the expectation of the
quadratic variation and
it's time one
and really what we
what we established here is that
the expectation of
d
uh the quadratic variation
at any time t
is equal
to DT
times
t
times the expectation
of the gradient of f
it's
x d
squared
so
if if you want like I think a good
intuition for this so
deal of the quadratic variations then
the instantaneous change in quadratic
variation is just telling us how fast
this Martingale empty is moving so it's
kind of like how much information I'm
getting about the value of f
when I go from T to t plus DT
and
it's equal to just are you missing a
factor of two
I am a center Factor too thanks
uh
uh and and the instantaneous you know
that basically the speed of the
Martingale Mt just depends on you know
how big the gradient of f is at the
point x d
okay and usually when we prove
concentration and the qualities we want
like concentration inequalities usually
have to do with the variance on one side
and things that have to do with like
local
changes of f so that like derivatives of
n
but not at x t but you know at X1
so when we reach all the way to X1
so this is going to be helpful for us
and
as an exercise we want to now show you
it
how to prove
this theorem by telegrams
will actually prove two theorems by
telegram so this is the 10 from 94 or
something like this which is an
improvement on the pawn Korean quality
so the one Korean equality says that you
know the variance uh is at most let me
write it like this the expectation
of
uh
the gradient
squared of that right this is just
like the sum of influences
so telegram proof so this is important
correct telegram proved basically that I
can remove the square here
which only makes this smaller because
you know each partial derivative is
either minus one zero or one
so
you know when I Square it
uh
yeah so so you know the the gradient
square has to be an integer
meaning that when I take the square root
I only make it smaller
up to some constant
okay if you I mean
this
doesn't look familiar sometimes this
thing is also
called I mean denoted by the expectation
of the sensitivity of it
where the sensitivity of f is just how
many coordinates
uh
can I start the square root of the
sensitivity of it
where the sensitivity of f is how many
coordinates I can toggle and this is
gonna toggle the value of that
at the point
right
it doesn't sound familiar
okay and now let's try to prove uh this
fact
so we're going to use this
representation
so you know
I just want to to bound uh this integral
by uh
by this
and the main Lemma is going to to be the
following thing
okay actually
yeah
so the main Lama is going to be that
I'm going to fix some Universal constant
whose value will be chosen later
okay let's let's just do it like that
start I'm a bit messy right
let's let's define a stopping time tall
to be
the minimal
time t
such that
the norm of the gradient of F at x t
is at least
this constant
and
our main level
is going to be
maybe let me
let me write it like this so minimum
with plus infinity so it could be that
this event never happens
if this event never happens I just you
know Define thought to be plus infinity
and the main Lemma is going to be that
the probability that tau is less than
infinity
actually less sorry
let's call this one
because anyway time is is between zero
and one I just want to keep the notation
the list
what what you want how to be an infinite
again sorry I couldn't hear you want how
to be an infinite or a minimum
uh
um it doesn't matter uh yeah it does
matter uh
well
I I didn't really stay let's say
infinite okay
sure this is not continuous and I
actually
did not say whether you know the process
XD is right or left continuous so at the
point of the jump it's not clear you
know if you've already jumped or not
so let's let's just write infinity
so
I want to say that the probability that
toe is less than one is at least
some other constant C Prime Times
the variance of that
meaning that you know the probability
that
there is a time where the gradient
is at least order a constant
is at least you know some constant times
the variance of it
foreign
so the main fact we're going to use here
is again
recall that XT is a martial
with
IID coordinates
which we already saw that this implies
that the gradient of f
at x t
is also important
remember because you know each
coordinate of the gray of the gradient
of f is but is in itself a multi-linear
function so we can just take the Fourier
decomposition I mean
it's it's just the sum of products of
independent marginals
and
then the answer the quality implies
that
the expectation of
so so maybe
the euclidean norm is a convex function
and therefore Yan sends inequality
implies that the expectation of the norm
of the gradient of F at X1
is bigger or equal
given
um
X at the stopping time tone
is big or equal
than the norm of the gradient of s it
takes two
right
so now
we have that
the expectation
of the gradient of f
at X1
which is equal to the right hand side of
the earth of
the inequality we want to prove
right we wanted to prove
that this is big
so this is bigger or equal
than
the expectation
um
the indicator that this stopping time
tall is less than one times
the norm of the gradient of F at X
at this time Tom
but by definition
is bigger than some constant C
by definition of the Stop and time right
so that's bigger equal than the
probability that store is less than one
which is by the Lemma
big or equal than you know sorry there
is a
D here
which is by the Lemma bigger than
3 times the Prime Times
the variance
tell lesson one
starting should be probably the Italian
sorry strictly less than one
thank you
okay
right so all we want to show is
Islam
and this Lemma really follows from I
mean
a completely General Lemma about
martingales so
let's call it Lemma Prime
if empty is animal
such that
M at time one
is
maybe I don't even
any martingales such that
em at time one is always plus minus one
and
empty in absolute value is less than one
for all t
which our Martingale satisfies
then
the probability
that
may maybe let me write it like that
now that's
then the probability
that the quadratic variation of M at
time one is bigger
than some constant
so there exists a universal constant
is the police this constant times
the variance
of M1
so
what does this llama say this Lama says
you know
um
recall that we know by ito's isometry
that the expectation of the quadratic
variation Time 1 is equal to the
variance of M1
so this glamor says a bit I mean
it's just as you know not only in
expectation
the mark the quadratic variation is big
but also there is a non-negligible
probability that the quadratic variation
is bigger than a constant it couldn't be
that the fact that this expectation is
big is only due to a very small
probability event in which the quadratic
variations you know is just huge
there is it's actually quite likely that
the quadratic variation will be you know
bigger than something
now I I'll will take a break in one
minute but
let's see how this like how Lemma Prime
implies uh okay maybe
let me call it lemon okay Power llama
Prime
implies uh lemon a
so
why does B imply n
well
um
the quadratic variation of
of M it's time one is just
uh
the integral of T times the gradient of
f squared
x t
foreign
okay you know what I
I need to write let's take a break and I
mean okay in ideologically
it's
it's this and you know if if whenever
this is
bigger than a constant there must be
like
an instant where this is also bigger
than constant
only this inequality is this equality is
not exactly true
it's true in expectation but it's not
exactly true without an expectation so
let's uh leave this for the next for
after the break
thank you
any questions
foreign
so in the in llama Prime I was confused
about the definition of Mt like so you
said that Mt is in plus minus one but
then also the magnitude is bounded by
one for all T so
uh ah sorry sorry M1 yeah I'm really
glad some people are paying attention
sorry it's a Martingale that so so think
about f of x t what do we know about it
at time one at the final time
this is a Boolean function so it's it
has to be plus minus one
and at any given time it's somewhere in
between
and it starts from the expectation of it
sorry this this has to be yeah
thanks
yeah there's some more questions
hi uh so uh the first the coordinate
trivial process right uh so it's kind of
giving you conditional like like when
you're doing the process it's kind of
giving you conditional expectations uh
of f right so like so what can so when
you're doing this process like uh like
what are the I mean you're getting some
information about it but like how what
kind of I don't know it's different but
I like what kind of information is this
that's one question the second thing is
uh like like how do you choose this
process in the sense that you have this
process like say I'm trying to bond the
way uh the variance and somehow you're
I'm thinking of uh this process as like
writing down an expression uh of some
nature and somehow this this
particular process is seems to be more
effective right so how like where is
that like uh how do you sense that uh
some choice of process is more
effectively yeah
and
um okay yeah
so so later on it's going to okay so so
let me answer your first question first
so you know it's still some conditional
expectation it's always the case that
right that like f of x t i mean I should
have said it but
so thanks for pointing this out it's a
Martingale it's always you know the
conditional expectation of f of X1
given x t
so
the first the coordinate revealment
process XT was like on these points
and now x t is going to be like you know
here and then here
and then here Etc
so I I mean I'm not sure I have anything
else to say about it but but
each of these processes gives rise to a
sequence of conditional expectations now
why is that you know process of the red
points better than the process of like
the
uh green points
um so we are actually we we haven't used
it yet but we are actually gonna use the
fat that
um later on
that like uh
the the normal for every chord and it is
always T so
if if you want this this is kind of like
uh
this is very related to uh the notion of
noise stability
so it's uh not hard to see that
the expectation of f of x t
squared
is just equal to the
to stability of it
so we're not going to use this directly
but ideologically this will be kind of
something well used
um
no thanks there was one more question
yeah yeah hi so I was thinking like you
can sort of couple the Green Point at
the right point right like
um because you don't jump like uh five
and many many times after like uh T
larger than Epsilon so can think of it
as like for example a random point on
the Epson Cube and then you sample a
bunch of random coordinates to jump and
then sort of the green process and the
red process becomes the same and wait
wait I don't see how to couple them
actually can you can you oh oh I'm
saying like oh it's not a coupling but
there's some corresponding like
um
you can't Define them in the same
property space in the following way
first you sample so because after T
larger than Epsilon there's only going
to be uh finally many uh jumps so uh you
could just think of it as I just start
at T equals Epsilon so I sample random
point it's not a problem so we start
like here
yeah yeah we sample a random point on
the Epsilon Cube
yeah and sure then there will only be a
finite many uh final number of jumps so
for I could just for every coordinate a
finite number of jumps sure yeah yeah
but I only have n coordinates so and I
can define a discrete process uh which
each time it picks one coordinate right
random coordinate and then it jumps in
that coordinate like flip the sign
yeah but but it's not going to be with
probability half and half anymore right
because you've already revealed a little
bit of like what the coordinates is
going to be
oh yeah that's true
I see yeah
but I I guess like you can also discard
I mean you can also discretize this
uh red process and it becomes this yeah
just like the green one yeah we you know
you can take DT to be you can actually
DT doesn't have to be infinitesimal but
it's going to be convenient for us later
on
yeah I see
um thanks
any final questions
not let's thank Ronin again
we'll reconvene at two